- Congratulations, this is really awesome.
You're officially a college graduate.
That's amazing that you went back,
nobody does that.
- You know what I did?
I kind of never really left school.
And my teachers, like when I was taking
a leave of absence to start working
and to do "The Village"
and stuff like that.
I kept saying to my teachers, I'm like,
"I'm gonna come back, I'm gonna come back,
"I'm gonna come back."
And right away, I started taking classes
at an accredited university
in order to transfer
to eventually graduate.
I didn't think it was
gonna take me 21 years.
(laughing)
- Yeah well, you've been a little busy
making huge, successful movies.
So yeah, not that they need to be huge
and successful, but they are.
So I just think it's awesome.
My mom's a teacher so when I told her
I wasn't going to college
and I was gonna be
a waitress living on a
mattress to be a singer,
it wasn't the best thing she'd ever heard.
(laughing)
She wasn't very excited about the notion.
So it worked out luckily.
- Yeah, yeah it did.
- So how did you celebrate?
'Cause so many things,
like I had my birthday
in quarantine, everybody's
had like moments.
Anniversaries, stuff like that happening
in quarantine, how'd you
celebrate graduating?
- Do you know what, it was
really kind of amazing.
Like my parents got one of those things,
one of those signs that you can like
put in the grass in front of your house
that's like "Congratulations
Graduate Bryce"
or whatever, (laughing)
- Oh my gosh,
that's so southern.
- They're like parents
that have a graduate and I had,
my husband sent off this
thing called Tribute
where you can just like record tributes
for people and so he's sent it
to all of my friends and family
and folks that I've known
forever and ever and ever
and they all recorded
videos just, you know,
being lovely and
congratulating me and all that.
- That's really sweet.